.
Rockmusik ist für mich der Herzschlag
aus dem tiefen Untergrund,
ein Ausdruck
von musikalischer Freiheit.
* Chinesische Rockmusik *
Wie klingt Rockmusik made in China?
Gibt es in China
eine freie Musikszene?
Und bekomme ich Antworten
auf heikle Fragen?
* Chinesische Rockmusik *
Mein Name ist Pascal Nufer.
Fünf Jahre lang berichtete ich
als Korrespondent aus China.
Es war eine spannende,
aber auch zermürbende Zeit,
geprägt von einem ständigen Katz-
und Maus-Spiel mit den Behörden.
Jetzt will ich dem Land
eine zweite Chance geben.
Ich möchte die Menschen erleben
und nicht den mächtigen Staat.
Ich will mich mit China versöhnen.
Wow.
- Wow.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
Schanghai, die Finanzmetropole -
von hier aus berichtete ich
über das riesige Land.
Die Ereignisse aus Wirtschaft
und Politik nahmen mich gefangen.
Mein Wunsch, die unabhängige
Musikszene kennenzulernen,
blieb unerfüllt.
Heute Abend treffe ich einen Freund,
der mir vielleicht helfen kann,
diesen Wunsch doch noch zu erfüllen.
Er ist wie ich Schweizer,
heisst Florian Rudin,
kam als Ingenieur nach China
und wurde hier zum Rockmusiker.
Auf dem Shanghai Tower
war ich auch noch nie.
Ich find ihn geil
von der Architektur her.
Während ich mich als Korrespondent
mit der Bürokratie herumschlug,
sank er immer tiefer ins Land ein.
Er ist mittlerweile
mit einer Chinesin verheiratet.
Vielleicht kann er mir eine Tür in
den musikalischen Untergrund öffnen?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Er spricht chinesisch. *
Und wie viele Schläge
haben wir jetzt?
Si, si, si, si, si, si, si, si.
Florian führt seit zwei Jahren
eine Musikschule.
Besonders beliebt sind die Kurse
für Kinder im Vorschulalter.
Zusammen mit Geschäftspartner Eniaut
führt er die Kinder
spielerisch in die Musik ein.
Für einmal ist nicht der Druck da,
den man sich vom Schulsystem
in China her gewohnt ist.
Es ist ein bisschen menschlicher,
als es sonst zu und her geht,
auch mit all den Ansprüchen,
die ständig da sind.
Wir wollen keine Ansprüche
an unsere Schüler stellen.
Es ist ein persönlicher Weg.
Und wir sind da, um diese
Leidenschaft zu unterstützen.
# I've got this feeling
inside my bones.
# It turns electric ...
Zuerst war Florian
der Klavierlehrer meiner Tochter.
So lernte ich ihn kennen.
Irgendwann liess auch ich mich an-
stecken und nahm Gitarrenunterricht.
# I've got sunshine in my pocket.
Florians Methoden
sind neu für Schanghai,
trotzdem oder gerade deshalb
floriert die Schule.
Die Kundschaft ist kosmopolitisch -
wie die Chinesin Coco,
die im Ausland studierte.
Meine Tochter
soll mit Musik aufwachsen.
Und ich habe diese Schule gewählt,
weil ich
den Unterrichtsstil sehr mag.
Eniaut sagte,
es gehe hier nicht um Technik,
es gehe zu Beginn nicht um
das Beherrschen eines Instruments,
sondern darum, Spass zu haben.
Du lernst also bereits
Englisch und Musik?
Als Musiklehrer kenne ich Florian,
doch jetzt will ich ihn als
Rockmusiker mit seiner Band erleben.
Zusammen mit meinem Team, mit Pro-
duzent Beat und Kameramann Andreas,
fahre ich zu einer Probe
von Florians Band.
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
Der Proberaum liegt mitten
im Zentrum der 23-Mio.-Metropole
in einem Büro- und Wohnkomplex.
Wo ist die Nummer 13?
- Die 13?
Ja, das muss hier sein.
Da vorne rechts,
dann links, dann sind sie da.
Okay.
Hallo, Flo.
- Na, du. Ihr habt's geschafft.
Ist ja schräg,
in einem Wohn-Compound drin.
Ja, v.a., wenn man uns
von aussen hört.
Ja, das Schlagzeug,
wenn man genau hinhört.
Hier runter?
- Ja.
Hallo, schön, dich zu sehen.
Eniaut, Florian
und drei chinesische Mitmusiker
gründeten vor Kurzem die Band
Shanghai Qiutian -
Schanghai im Herbst, benannt
nach der schönsten Jahreszeit hier.
Ihr Ziel ist es,
der engagierten Rockmusik
in China mehr Gehör zu verschaffen.
Die meisten Jungen in China
spielen Videogames,
sie konsumieren und empfangen nur.
Mit unserer Band wollen wir zeigen,
wie toll es ist, zusammen
eigene Songs zu entwickeln.
Dass der Austausch innerhalb
der Band und mit dem Publikum
einfach Spass macht.
* Verspielte Jazzmusik *
So, wie ich das wahrnehme,
ist Rockmusik in China
nicht wirklich angesehen,
z.B. als Job.
Meine chinesischen Schwiegereltern
finden:
"Was? Du willst jetzt
noch mehr Musik machen?"
"Wie steht's eigentlich
um deine Ingenieursausbildung?"
Am nächsten Tag.
Florian hat
einen Konzertabend organisiert
für drei befreundete Bands
und Shanghai Qiutian.
Die Vorbereitungen waren aufwendig.
Es dauerte Wochen, bis er alle
Bewilligungen beisammenhatte.
Wir müssen immer alle Bands
auflisten, alle ihre Songs.
Auch werden
sämtliche Songtexte überprüft
oder müssen
zumindest vorgelegt werden.
Das muss von einem Büro
bestätigt werden.
* Verspielte Jazzmusik *
Wir mussten
auch schon Videos einschicken,
anhand derer geprüft wurde,
ob wir uns auf der Bühne
konform verhalten.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass die Zensurbehörde
wirklich jede Songzeile überprüft.
Und ein bisschen erstaunt mich,
dass es Florian
so gar nicht zu stören scheint.
Wir lassen uns von dieser
Einschränkung nicht einschränken
und verwirklichen uns trotzdem.
Wir lassen die Sau raus
während des Musizierens.
Wir schreiben Songtexte,
veröffentlichen Songs.
Wir lassen uns
künstlerisch nicht einschränken.
Vielleicht, ohne dass wir es merken,
bewegen wir uns bereits
mit dem Strom.
Ja, vielleicht ist uns
das gar nicht bewusst
oder wir sind bereits brainwashed.
Aber bis jetzt sage ich,
was ich sagen will.
Wir spielen zum Glück
keinen Polit-Punk.
Irgendwie fühlen wir uns
noch etwas alternativ. Doch, ja.
Ich hatte bisher nie das Gefühl,
dass ich eingeschränkt werde.
* Sanfte Rockmusik *
# Xin Shidai - Ein neues Zeitalter.
# Gongxiang Weilai -
Eine gemeinsame Zukunft.
# Xin Shidai - Ein neues Zeitalter.
# Xianzai - Jetzt.
Das Konzert war toll,
die Stimmung im Saal wunderbar.
Doch es hat mich
nachdenklich gestimmt,
wie unerbittlich die Zensur
heute im Konzertbereich eingreift.
Er sagt:
"Wir sind keine politische Band."
Aber das ist die Folge,
dass sich gar keine Band
mehr getraut, politisch zu sein.
Aber als Musiker,
wenn ich wirklich Musik mache,
weil ich Musik machen will,
weil mir das wichtig ist,
dann kann ich verstehen,
dass sie das so machen.
Die strikte Zensur
hat auch meine Arbeit als Korres-
pondent immer schwieriger gemacht.
Immer weniger Menschen waren bereit,
über "heikle" Themen zu sprechen.
Auch im Quartier,
in dem mein Büro lag,
vervielfachte sich
die Zahl der Kameras.
Die Regierung
schaut heute in jeden Winkel.
Und: nachbarschaftliche Quartiere
verschwinden, eins ums andere.
In China dreht sich heute alles
um Profitdenken und Konsumieren.
Ich will eine Frau treffen,
die sieben Jahre lang
einen Ort der Gegenkultur
am Laufen hielt - und zwar illegal.
Echt, was für ein Ort.
Hallo! Rainbow?
Ja, am Apparat.
Wir sind da, ich sehe den McDonald's.
Sind wir am richtigen Ort?
Hinter dem McDonald's?
Gleich neben McDonald's findet hier
der neue Underground statt.
Hallo. Sind wir hier richtig?
Der Klub von Rainbow?
Ja, genau.
- Hallo. Wir sind zu dritt.
Okay.
Ich kenne Rainbow
aus ihrem alten Klub The Mansion,
einem der letzten
Freiräume der Stadt,
einem Paralleluniversum,
wo sich die Kreativszene traf.
Wie weit runter geht es noch?
Vor ein paar Monaten
musste sie schliessen.
Nun hat sie etwas Neues eröffnet.
Underground! Das ist Underground!
Okay.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie Rainbow in ihrem neuen Klub
mit der Zensur umgeht.
Jetzt sind wir, glaub ...
Nein?
* Pulsierende Technoklänge *
Okay. Okay.
Ah, da bist du ja.
Hallo, Pascal. Schön, dich zu sehen.
Wie geht es dir?- Prima.
Ich war irritiert,
ob ich hier richtig bin.
Ja, du bist richtig hier.
Das ist also hier das neue Mansion?
- Ja, genau.
Wow, das hat sich sehr verändert.
- Total verändert, ja.
Was läuft heute Abend?
Heute Abend haben wir einen
DJ-Kurs - limitiert auf 30 Leute.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir hier
noch eine Fitness-Party.
Eine Fitness-Party?
One, two - hey remember:
shovel, shovel!
Mit ihrem neuen Klub ist Rainbow
nun also voll im Kommerz angekommen:
Fitness-Partyes und DJ-Schule.
Wir haben hier den Masterausgang,
die Kabel gehen zu den Boxen.
* Lebhafte Beats *
Hier erfahre ich,
dass Rainbow ihren neuen Klub
nicht nur mit dem Einverständnis
der Regierung eröffnet hat,
sondern in ihrem Auftrag.
Früher Betreiberin
eines illegalen Klubs -
und jetzt im Dienst
der chinesische Regierung?
Ja, genau.
Das ist ein grosser Sprung.
Ich musste das Mansion
illegal führen,
denn das chinesische Gesetz war
sehr rückständig auf unserem Gebiet.
Ich hatte keine andere Möglichkeit.
Aber die Stadtregierung
hat verstanden, was ich wollte.
Sie wussten jederzeit, was ich tat.
Und sie wollten mich
auf keinen Fall stoppen.
Sie stehen voll hinter mir.
Wow, so geht das also.
Ich bin echt perplex.
Ich will mehr
von ihrem Deal erfahren.
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
Schanghai hat sich verändert.
- Ja, sehr.
Vor etwa neun Monaten haben sie
in Schanghai in einer Nacht
6'000 Klubs geschlossen,
inklusive aller Saunabars.
Das ganze zwielichtige Gewerbe
haben sie dichtgemacht.
Sie haben damit
das Nachtleben zerstört.
Wollen Sie
ein kontrollierbares Nachtleben?
Nein, ein innovatives Nachtleben.
Jede Stadtregierung in China
spricht davon.
Jede grosse Stadt hat ein Budget,
um Nachtleben zu entwickeln,
aber sie wissen nicht, wie das geht.
Deshalb haben sie in Schanghai
nun also Rainbow engagiert.
Ah, it's in the same place as
Harley's. Now I understand.
In einer Bar
erfahre ich mehr über den Deal.
Rainbow erhält bei den Liegenschaften
und mit Werbung über staatliche
Medien volle Unterstützung.
Und dafür hält sie sich
an die staatlichen Vorgaben.
Die Stadtregierung hat die Kontrolle
über die Musik- und Klubszene
in Schanghai voll übernommen.
Zeit für mich, um weiterzuziehen.
Wir fahren nach Peking.
* Chinesische Durchsage *
Florian meinte, wenn ich mehr über
Rockmusik in China erfahren wolle,
müsse ich unbedingt nach Peking,
es sei das Zentrum der Szene.
Auf meiner Suche
nach einer unabhängigen Musikszene
fahre ich also in die Hauptstadt.
* Treibende elektronische Klänge *
Hier gebe es jemanden, der
die Rockszene präge wie kein anderer
und um Freiräume kämpfe, so Florian.
Er ist der Besitzer des
grössten Rockmusik-Labels in China.
Im Westen heissen sie: EMI,
Warner und Sony - hier: Modern Sky.
Also nicht hier an diesem Ort.
Gehen wir mal rein.
Zusammen mit meinem Dolmetscher
treffe ich den Besitzer Shen Luhui.
Hallo.
- Freut mich, mein Name ist Pascal.
Ah, du sprichst Chinesisch?
- Ja, es geht.
Sex, Drugs and Internet -
ein vielsprechender Willkommensgruss.
Hier war früher das Militär drin.
Das hier war einmal ein Zeughaus.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten hier?
- Hier in Peking?
Ja, hier im Haus.
- Ungefähr 200 Leute.
Die private Firma Modern Sky
vertritt 300 Bands
aus Rock, Hip-Hop,
Electro, Folk und World music.
Sie unterhält eigene Vertriebskanäle
und eine Musik-Downloadplattform.
Die Firma hat Rockmusik
in den letzten 20 Jahren
aus der Nische
in den Mainstream gebracht.
Bevor er mit dem Label begann,
war Lihui selbst Musiker.
Das warst du?
- Ja.
Das war ein Stück
der B-Seite unseres Albums.
* Sanfte Rockmusik *
Das war von Anfang
alles andere als brave Musik.
Und wir trugen lange Haare
und Schlaghosen.
Wir galten als die Bad Boys.
Der einstige Bad Boy ist heute
ein gewiefter Geschäftsstratege
Das ist eine Kooperation mit Nike -
Werbefiguren.
Ich und einige Mitarbeitende
standen Modell.
Das Interesse an Rockmusik
in China wächst laufend,
Modern Sky wird immer grösser.
Ich frage Lihui, wie er mit
der Zensurbehörde zusammenarbeitet,
ob er Kompromisse herausholen kann.
Wenn ein Song
keine Erlaubnis bekommt,
dann kann man ihn nicht publizieren,
da kann man nichts machen.
Meistens kann man die Band davon
überzeugen, das Lied abzuändern.
Das sind eben Sachen,
die man nicht unter Kontrolle hat.
Für uns ist wichtig,
mit allen zu reden.
Und wenn sich eine Band
nicht flexibel zeigt ...
Ich meine, wir sind breit
aufgestellt und können reagieren,
für uns ist das Risiko
nicht so hoch.
Jegliche politische und sozial-
kritische Äusserung wird zensiert.
Einige Rap-Bands von Modern Sky,
die sich dem widersetzten,
erhielten gar
generelles Auftrittsverbot.
Zum Schluss frage ich Lihui, ob es
für ihn nicht interessanter wäre,
im Ausland zu arbeiten -
ohne die Zensur?
Meine Zukunft ist hier.
China bietet mir immer noch
sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Die jungen Menschen hier
sind verbunden mit der Welt.
Die Jungen im Westen
haben keine Ahnung von China.
Aber hier verstehen die Jungen
beide Welten -
und deshalb kann hier
so viel Kreatives entstehen.
Das macht's für mich hier
einfach interessant.
Lihui hat mir noch gesagt,
dass Modern Sky am Wochenende
ein Open-Air-Rockfestival
veranstaltet - da will ich hin.
Ich reise in die südliche
Küstenstadt Xiamen und will erleben,
was in China auf
der grossen Rockbühne stattfindet.
* Sphärische Trompetenklänge *
Xiamen -
eine 3,5-Mio.-Einwohner-Metropole.
Das Festival
findet direkt am Meer statt.
An diesem Wochenende begleitet mich
meine ehemalige Assistentin Tian.
Wir sind rechtzeitig da für den
ersten grossen Act - Rapper Tizzy T.
Die Casting Show "Rap Of China"
machte ihn 2017 über Nacht zum Star.
Zwei Stunden vor Konzertbeginn
stehen die Fans schon Schlange.
Das sind also
die chinesischen Rap-Fans.
Rap-Musik ist für uns im Westen
die Musik der bösen Buben,
der bösen Mädchen.
Wie ist das für dich?
Für mich ist das nicht so.
Im Hip-Hop geht es einfach
um einen persönlichen Standpunkt.
Warum magst du Tizzy T?
Ich finde ihn charmant.
Ja, er ist einfach charmant.
Du findest ihn charmant.
Und was hältst du von seiner Musik?
Seine Songs
sind einfach faszinierend.
Und er ist wirklich talentiert,
darum hat man ihn einfach gern.
* Chinesische Ansage von Tizzy T *
* Ruhiger Hip-Hop-Song
"Crossed your Body" von Tizzy T *
Okay, okay, der charmante Tizzy T
geht in seinen Texten
ziemlich zur Sache.
Nun bin ich mal gespannt
auf diesen Tizzy T.
Hallo, schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ah, so gut.
Tizzy, ich hab eine Frage an dich:
Bist du mein Kumpel?
Ja, genau, ich bin dein Kumpel.
Das ist dein Slogan, nicht?
- Ja.
Ich bin auf der Suche nach den
wilden Kerlen auf Chinas Musikbühnen.
Bist du ein wilder Kerl?
Als ich damit anfing,
fragte ich mich,
warum Rap nicht auch
etwas Leichtes haben kann,
warum soll man im Rap
nicht auch mal lachen dürfen?
Muss im Hip-Hop
alles so sein wie bei Eminem? Nein.
Ich finde,
alle haben ihren eigenen Stil,
China hat seinen eigenen Hip-Hop.
So soll es sein.
Was meinten deine Eltern dazu,
als du ihnen gesagt hast,
dass du Rapper werden willst?
Was?
Ich wollte Musik machen, aber
ich wuchs in einer Kleinstadt auf.
Und da macht einfach niemand Musik,
wirklich niemand.
Also, ich kannte niemanden.
Die Leute meinten,
von Musik könne man doch
nicht leben, das sei unmöglich.
Sie hatten das einfach so im Kopf.
Aber mich konnte niemand
daran hindern, es doch zu versuchen.
Und heute?
Sind sie stolz auf dich?
Ja, meine Mutter meinte kürzlich:
"Gut, hast du nicht auf uns gehört
und bist nicht arbeiten gegangen."
Danke dir, Tizzy,
du bist mein Kumpel.
Ja, ich bin dein Kumpel.
Hey!
Noch ein Foto?
Tizzy T - ein wirklich charmanter
und eloquenter junger Mann.
Seine Texte sind etwas anrüchig,
aber harmlos.
Wirklich nichts mit wildem Kerl -
hier jedenfalls nicht.
Meine Dolmetscherin Tian
empfiehlt mir am nächsten Tag
ein Konzert auf der Nebenbühne.
* Rasante Gitarrenklänge *
Und tatsächlich - das Publikum
tanzt hier unter der Regenbogenfahne,
dem Symbol für Aufbruch und Toleranz.
Hier spielt die Musik.
Hier gefällt's mir.
* Rasante Rockmusik *
* Klicken *
Wow!
Ziemlich verschwitzt.
Die Band heisst Birdstriking,
zu Deutsch:
Vogelschlag, ein Zusammenprall
von Vögeln und Flugzeugen.
Und der Drummer der Band
nennt sich Neo -
wie der Held aus dem Film "Matrix".
Das klingt schon eher
nach wilden Kerlen.
Was wollt ihr dem Publikum mitgeben
mit eurer Musik?
Wir wollen die Menschen ermutigen,
das zu tun, was sie wirklich wollen.
Es geht uns um Energie,
um Gefühle, Liebe.
Junge Leute ermutigen,
für ihr eigenes Leben zu kämpfen.
Was sind die nächsten Schritte?
Bei euch tut sich ja einiges?
Wir werden wahrscheinlich bei einer
TV-Show mitmachen - nächsten Sommer.
Diese TV-Shows
sind in China sehr wichtig.
Wie wird das
eure Karriere beeinflussen?
Künftig werden wir
mit Konzerten Geld verdienen
und nicht mehr drauflegen wie jetzt.
Mehr Leute werden uns sehen.
Und sich wegen der TV-Shows
für Rockmusik interessieren.
Mehr Leute werden den Wert
von dem erkennen, was wir tun.
Macht ihr die Dokumentation
nur hier in dieser Stadt?
Nein, wir sind wieder in Peking
nächste Woche.
Dort spielen wir
nächste Woche auch wieder.
Unser Konzert.
Ja, nächstes Wochenende,
2. November.
Dann sind wir wieder in Peking.
Dann haben wir unser
Zehn-Jahre-Jubiläumskonzert.
Wirklich?
- Kommst du?
2. November? Klar.
Ja, verpass das nicht!
Ich schicke dir die Angaben.
Cool, vielen Dank euch.
Also für mich war das
ein sehr schöner Moment,
als mir Neo sein WeChat gegeben hat.
Da dachte ich: "Genau, ja hoffentlich
können wir die nochmals treffen."
Und das klappt ja jetzt,
wenn alles gut geht.
Ich erhoffe mir sehr,
dass da noch etwas mehr kommt,
damit wir diese Welt dieser
jungen Leute besser verstehen können,
die sich völlig von der Welt
derjenigen Bands unterscheidet,
die vor 20 Jahren
hier angefangen haben,
als hier alles
noch viel offener war.
* Sphärische Trompetenklänge *
Meine Suche nach den freien Stimmen
auf Chinas Rockbühnen
führt mich also zurück nach Peking.
Und das Wiedersehen mit Neo
findet tatsächlich statt.
Kannst du lesen?
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Okay, mit Fleisch? Oder ohne?
Für mich ... Was für Fleisch ist es?
Es gibt Schwein oder Rind.
Was zu Trinken?
Kurz vor dem Jubiläumskonzert
treffen wir uns in einem Nudelimbiss.
Auch Neo hat offensichtlich
Freude am Wiedersehen.
Er will uns
die nächsten Tage begleiten
und mir die wichtigsten Leute
der lokalen Indie-Szene vorstellen.
Noch eine letzte Stärkung,
dann muss er zum Soundcheck.
Und ich treffe vor dem Konzert
eine Frau,
von der ich schon viel gehört habe.
Hi, ich bin Pascal
- Wie geht's?
Gut.
- Ich bin Kang Mao.
Schön, dich endlich zu treffen.
- Ja.
Gehen wir rein?
Zum Jubiläumskonzert
hat die Band alle eingeladen,
die in Pekings Musikszene
Rang und Namen haben.
Kang Mao ist Sängerin
der legendären Punkband Subs
und gehört zur alten Garde.
Ich habe
noch nie von der Band gehört.
Ja, aber sie kennen dich natürlich.
Wirklich? Das tut mir leid.
Insgeheim hoffte ich,
Kang Mao auf dieser Reise zu treffen.
Und jetzt steht sie hier.
Lange war unklar,
ob sie in der Stadt ist.
Sie soll das Gewissen
der hiesigen Rockszene sein.
Eine der wenigen, die sich
noch offen politisch äussern.
Wenn wir
an die Gesellschaft hier denken,
dann kommt bei uns die Wut hoch.
Deshalb brauchen wir Musik -
sie ist für uns wie eine Waffe.
Mit der Musik
wollen wir die Welt verändern.
Wir wollen damit den Menschen laut
zurufen: "Wacht auf, wacht auf!"
Wir haben Grund, wütend zu sein.
Ich bin beeindruckt
von so viel Offenheit.
Kang Mao lädt mich spontan
zu ihrer nächsten Bandprobe ein.
Und während wir reden
und auf den Konzertbeginn warten,
taucht plötzlich die Polizei auf.
Und wir dürfen drinnen
nicht mehr filmen.
Nach einer halben Stunde
ist der Spuk vorbei.
Are you ready?
Die haben Urinproben genommen. Dabei
wurde bei mir noch nie was gefunden.
Sie kamen
und haben den Sänger getestet?
Ja, und mich.
- Dich auch?
Ja, obwohl die Tests
bei mir immer negativ waren.
Good luck for the show.
Die hatten jetzt echt Glück, dass sie
die Urinprobe vor Ort geben mussten -
oder durften -
und nicht aufs Revier mussten.
Das hätte genauso passieren können,
und dann wäre das Konzert
aus gewesen.
Solche Sachen passieren.
Und das ist einfach das,
was diese Szene auch kaputt macht.
* Sanfte Rockmusik *
Und dann geht's los,
als wäre nichts gewesen.
Von der Band fällt kein Wort
über die Polizeikontrolle.
Offenbar weiss man,
wann man besser schweigt.
Im Saal auch die Scouts
der TV-Show "Summer Of Bands",
an der Neo und seine Band
wohl bald auch teilnehmen werden.
Die Band gibt alles.
* Gitarren-Schlussakkord *
Auch der ehemalige Manager der Band
ist da.
Seid ihr zufrieden?
Was die Jungs zum Schluss
gemacht haben, war grossartig.
Das ist Michael Pettis
vom Label Maybe Mars.
Ich habe viel von dir gehört.
Hat dir die Show gefallen?
Ich liebe Birdstriking.
Und ihn mag ich besonders.
Am nächsten Morgen bin ich
wieder mit Neo verabredet.
Ah, hier.
Er hat arrangiert, dass wir Michael
Pettis noch einmal treffen können.
Kaum einer wisse mehr
über Chinas Rockmusik-Szene
als ihr alter Manager, meinte Neo.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Neo hat heute selbst
eine Videokamera mit dabei.
Für seinen Blog will er
eine Reportage über uns machen.
Das ist sein Haus?
Nicht schlecht.
Michael wohnt und arbeitet in
einem der letzten noch existierenden
traditionellen
Hutong-Viertel Pekings.
Hallo. Können wir reinkommen?
- Ja.
Auch He Fan ist hier,
der Sänger von Birdstriking.
Warst du schon mal hier?
Nein, zum ersten Mal.
Ist das das Büro von Maybe Mars?
Ich habe dich gerade auf WeChat
akzeptiert.- Auf WeChat, genau.
Du schaust zu beschäftigt aus.
Hallo.
Manchmal halte ich hier Vorlesungen
über Währungspolitik
und Finanzmärkte.
Ohne Bezug zur Musik?
Kein Musikbezug. Ich war an
der Wall Street, Wertpapierhändler.
Ich kam 2002 hierher,
um zu unterrichten und ...
Hey, Iggy, nein!
Iggy Dog, nicht Iggy Pop.
Er ist ein bisschen zu dick.
Für Iggy Pop?
- Ja.
Ein britisches Magazin listete uns
unter den fünf besten Labels
in ganz Asien als Nummer 1.
Das war vor einem Jahr
und freute uns sehr.
Aber ich habe Maybe Mars verkauft
vor zwei Jahren - an Taihe.
Was ändert damit? Taihe
ist ein kommerzielles Pop-Label,
das viel Geld mit Werbung verdient.
Und wir haben ständig
Geld verloren - von mir bezahlt.
Unser Konzept war einfach.
Wenn wir die Band wirklich mögen,
egal ob sie erfolgreich ist
oder nicht,
dann unterstützen wir sie zu 100 %.
Wir mussten verliebt sein
in die Band
und stolz,
dass wir sie vertreten dürfen.
Michael war nicht nur Band-Manager,
sondern führte in den Nullerjahren
in Peking auch den Klub D-22.
Das Buch kam 2009 heraus
und zeigt die ganze Szene.
Hier sind die Hedgehog,
die heute sehr bekannt sind.
Die ganze D-22-Szene.
Da ist Shouwang von
den Carsick Cars - alle sind drin.
Ich wusste, nach 15 Jahren
würde es in China
eine fantastische Musikszene geben.
Aber es brauchte nur drei Jahre.
Die Wirkung unseres Klubs war enorm.
Und Carsick Cars
waren eine Schlüsselband.
Viele Musikerinnen und Musiker
in ganz China erzählten mir später,
dass sie deren erstes Album kauften
und dabei realisierten:
"Wir in China können das auch,
nicht nur die Ausländer."
Ein befreiendes Gefühl.
Seither wächst die Szene
in alle Richtungen,
ständig kommen neue Bands hinzu.
Die Indie-Szene in Peking
ist jetzt wirklich gross.
und wie ich schon mal sagte
und nochmals sagen möchte,
eine der besten der Welt.
Und das da?
Das sind unsere zwei letzten Alben.
- Ja, von Birdstriking.
Wir wollen auch
mit der Grafik etwas auslösen.
Öffne dein Denken,
mach etwas Sinnvolles!
Sei wie ein Vogel,
befreie dein Denken!
Je länger ich mit Neo unterwegs bin,
umso mehr öffnet er sich.
Er meditiere täglich und sei
ein spirituell Suchender, sagt er.
Jahrzehntelang
ging es den Leuten in China
nur um wirtschaftliches Wachstum,
Armut überwinden,
ein komfortables Leben führen.
Aber ist das geschafft, merken die
Menschen, dass sie mehr brauchen.
Sie brauchen spirituelle Führung.
Die Menschen verlieren sich
in all den Veränderungen,
in dieser
rein wirtschaftlichen Welt.
Der Wettbewerb in China
ist sehr hoch.
Im täglichen Leben -
überall Wettbewerb.
Es ist wie beim Verkehr.
Ich mag das Leben hier nicht.
Überall viel zu viel Anspannung.
Aber ich sehe das
als persönliches Training.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich dem sonst begegnen soll.
* Sentimentale Klavierklänge *
Es ist eine Agentur für Bands.
Ah, sie kümmert sich
um die Finanzen.
Und um rechtliche Belange.
Die Musik ist ein Fluchtort für Neo,
leben kann er davon noch nicht.
Er arbeitet in einem
kleinen Start-up-Unternehmen.
Seine Aufgabe hier
ist der Aufbau einer Social-Media-
Plattform für Musikfans.
Mir scheint, in China
geht heute alles übers Handy?
Ja.
Auch diese Fernseh-Musik-Shows.
Kannst du da was zeigen?
Ja.
"The Voice of Germany"
auf Chinesisch.
Die erste Staffel
von "Summer of Bands"
hat 2019 eingeschlagen
wie eine Bombe.
Der Name der Gewinnerband:
die Neuen Hosen.
Das ist die Fernsehshow,
bei der ihr diesen Sommer
wahrscheinlich mitmachen werdet?
Ja. Alle, die ich kenne,
haben diese Serie gesehen.
Eine Riesengeschichte für
die chinesische Independent-Musik,
wirklich ein historischer Moment.
* Treibende Rockmusik *
Die Neuen Hosen wurde von einer
kleinen Indie-Band aus dem Nichts
zu einer Band, die heute in China
100 Mio. Menschen kennen.
Und diesen Weg wollen Birdstriking
nun auch gehen.
Was heisst das für die Band
in Sachen Zensur?
Neo zeigt mir
ein altes Video seiner Band.
Das ist ein Vogelkäfig.
Symbolisch gemeint.
Ausbrechen aus dem Käfig.
Und den Käfig zerstören.
Das ist eine sehr klare Botschaft.
Eine gefährliche Botschaft,
wirklich gefährlich.
* Wilde Rockmusik *
Wir werden das
wohl bald vom Netz nehmen.
Weil sich das
gegen euch wenden könnte?
Ja, und das ist es nicht wert.
Wir müssen das respektieren.
Interessant.
Kriegen wir
Schwierigkeiten deswegen,
ist es das einfach nicht wert.
Dann ist es das nicht wert.
- Nein, dann ist das nur dumm.
Aus Angst, sie könnten sich
ihre Karriere verbauen,
zensiert die Band
ihre eigene Geschichte.
Für mich entspricht das genau dem
Empfinden der letzten fünf Jahre.
Dinge die vor fünf Jahren
noch möglich waren,
sind heute nicht mehr möglich.
Die Grenzen werden enger gezogen.
So ein Video,
das eigentlich harmlos ist,
ist plötzlich nicht nur unerwünscht,
sondern kann für einen
gefährlich werden.
Und das habe ich auch
immer wieder erlebt,
dass Leute, die vor drei Jahren
noch offen mit mir geredet haben,
plötzlich kein Interview mehr
geben wollen.
Ich lasse Neo arbeiten und freue mich
jetzt aufs Wiedersehen mit Kang Mao,
der Punk-Musikerin, die ich an
Birdstriking-Konzert getroffen habe.
Mit dabei ist Wu Hao,
ihr Lebenspartner
und Gitarrist der Band Subs.
Wow. Ha, it's in the basement.
Langsam aber sicher
riecht's nach echtem Underground.
Good smell.
- Yeah.
Die Subs
teilen sich im zweiten Untergeschoss
mit anderen Bands
ein paar Übungsräume.
So tief unter dem Boden
kann man sogar in Peking
ganz offen über Zensur reden.
Viele Bands, die ich kenne,
haben heute Auftrittsverbot.
Die Zensur beeinflusst
die Musikszene sehr stark.
Und ich finde es immer schwieriger,
Liedtexte zu schreiben,
v.a. seit etwa drei Jahren, seit die
Zensur immer strikter geworden ist,
spüre ich eine innerliche Blockade,
wenn ich etwas schreiben möchte.
* Wilde Punkmusik *
Kang Mao singt heute auf Englisch.
und konkrete politische Texte
singt auch sie nicht mehr.
Sie umschreibt,
um bei der Zensur durchzukommen.
Doch die Polizei
findet immer wieder Gründe,
der Band den Auftritt kurzfristig zu
verweigern - wie kürzlich in Chengdu.
Die Situation war angespannt
wegen des neuen Raketenabwehrsystems
der Südkoreaner.
Und die Polizei
hielt uns für eine koreanische Band.
Aber weshalb sollten Subs
eine koreanische Band sein?
Nur weil es
einen koreanischen Sender
mit ähnlichem Namen - SBS - gibt?
Total absurd.
One.
Two.
Es ist ja sowieso
eine absurde Reise,
die wir hier auf Erden machen.
Und vielleicht existieren wir als
Band bald nur noch in absurder Form.
Wir treten nicht mehr auf
und existieren künftig
nur noch im Übungskeller.
* Wilde Punkmusik *
* Sie kreischt ins Mikrofon. *
* Die wilde Punkmusik verklingt. *
Meine Reise führt mich
noch einmal raus aus dem Untergrund.
Neo will mich zu einem weiteren
Urgestein der Pekinger Szene führen,
zu einem Konzertveranstalter.
Ein Gebäude, das Geschichte atmet.
Ein Musikklub,
seit zwei Jahren geschlossen,
weil nebenan Wohnraum
für hohe Parteikader entstehen soll.
Das hier war auch ein berühmter Klub?
Ja, berühmt.
Und legendär.
Ich habe hier oft gespielt.
Du hast hier auch gespielt?
Oft.
A lot of fully packed gigs.
Hier geht's
zum Büro des Veranstalters.
Hallo. Wie geht's?
Gut, gut.
Entschuldige die Verspätung.
Da ist er also: Gouzi - bei ihm
trifft sich Pekings Rockprominenz,
wie hier die Band Joyside,
noch eine Legende
aus Chinas Rockgeschichte.
Gouzi lebte lange in Berlin.
Jetzt organisiert er Konzerte
in China, rund 200 pro Jahr,
auch wenn dies mit der Zensur
immer anstrengender wird.
Man zahlt hohe Bussen,
singt eine Band ein falsches Wort.
Die haben eine Tabelle, wie viel man
pro nicht angegebenes Wort zahlt,
Ist dir das auch schon passiert?
Ja, wir mussten auch schon zahlen.
Deshalb sagen wir
den Bands heute klar,
dass sie wirklich
nur noch das singen dürfen,
was wir den Behörden
vorgelegt haben.
Wie hoch die Bussen waren,
wollte er nicht sagen.
Verbotene Worte
sind Namen von Parteikadern,
Worte wie Tibet
oder neuerdings Coronavirus.
Plakate erinnern an die
Aufbruchsjahre von Chinas Punkmusik.
Die Zensur und das grosse Geld hätten
den Widerstand von damals erstickt.
Doch das viele Geld heute
habe auch Vorteile.
Ich denke,
jetzt wo Rockbands in China
erstmals wirklich Geld verdienen,
werden sich auch mehr Leute
für diesen Weg entscheiden.
Ich sah schon so viele gute Bands,
die existieren nicht mehr,
weil sie nichts verdient haben.
Mich kümmert es nicht, ob diese
Castingshows via Streaming-TV
jetzt toll sind oder nicht so toll.
Hauptsache, die Bands
verdienen dadurch jetzt Geld.
Ist das hier
ein bekannter Konzertsaal?
Ja, sehr bekannt.
Es ist ernüchternd.
Die Zensur und das Geld
regieren die chinesische Rockszene.
Mal schauen, was mein letzter Abend
in Peking noch bringt.
Vielleicht gibt es doch noch
einen versöhnlichen Abschluss,
wenn heute Joyside abräumen.
Nach vielen Jahren Pause haben sie
sich erst kürzlich wieder vereint,
weil auch sie am neuen Wohlstand der
Rockmusik in China teilhaben wollen.
Ihr wart mal
in der Schweiz auf Konzerttour.
Welche Erinnerungen habt ihr daran?
Wir machten damals
eine Tour durch Europa.
Und für eine Nacht
waren wir in einem Hotel in Zürich.
Ich trank zu viel
und habe auf den Teppich gekotzt.
Und wir waren wohl auch etwas laut,
andere Gäste reklamierten.
Deswegen
büsste mich das Hotel mit 20 Euro.
This is really Rock'n'Roll.
Neo ist hier - und auch Kang Mao
schaut noch vorbei.
Die Familie trifft sich.
Und ich fühle mich
bereits als Teil davon.
In China backstage zu sein, ist
für mich eine ganz neue Erfahrung.
Sonst kommt man nirgends rein,
doch hier haben wir
vollen Zugang zu allem.
Das ist jetzt
wirklich mal was ganz anderes.
Wir dürfen überall hin,
wir dürfen mit allen reden,
wir dürfen hinter die Bühne.
Es freut mich sehr,
dass wir das noch erleben dürfen.
* Epische Rockmusik *
Ich habe meine Reise angetreten
mit dem Wunsch nach Versöhnung.
Und es hat sich für mich
eine neue Welt aufgetan,
eine Musikszene,
in der das Miteinander zählt.
Ich habe hier
eine Offenheit angetroffen,
wie ich es
nicht für möglich gehalten hätte.
Ich erinnere mich an all die Abende,
die wir schon
gemeinsam erlebt haben.
Wir sind arm,
aber wir teilen die Liebe zur Musik.
Das ist,
was Rock'n'Roll mit einem macht.
Das Schöne ist: Wir haben einander.
Das ist euer letzter Abend hier.
- Ja.
Wie steht es
um euren Dokumentarfilm?
Es läuft wirklich sehr gut.
Es übertrifft alle meine Erwartungen.
Wir starteten in Schanghai
und sind hier unverhofft
mitten im Zentrum
der Rockkultur Pekings gelandet.
Joyside haben so wie Birdstriking
beschlossen,
einen andern Weg einzuschlagen
als Kang Mao.
Sie wollen künftig
von ihrer Musik leben,
und ich kann es ihnen nicht verübeln.
Im Moment
spielen sie keine politischen Lieder,
aber füllen den Raum
mit Lebensfreude.
* Wilde Punkrockmusik *
So offen und natürlich
habe ich die Chinesen selten erlebt,
auch zu uns.
Man fühlt sich wie zu Hause.
Ich fühle mich hier echt
wirklich wie zu Hause.
Ich kann nicht mehr unterscheiden,
ob das chinesische Musiker sind
oder ob die aus dem Zürcher Oberland
kommen oder irgendwoher.
Es sind junge Leute, ältere Leute,
die einfach Freude
an der Musik haben.
Und es fasziniert mich,
dass es das gibt.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Die Rockmusik bewegt sich in China
unter dem Druck der Zensur
ganz Richtung Kommerz.
Ob sich daraus
etwas Positives entwickelt?
Wie auch immer, heute Abend
jedenfalls geht auch mein Herz auf.
Irgendwie fühle ich mich als Teil
dieser eingeschworenen Gemeinschaft.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020